maybe it's time to get rid of your ex's
plush toy or their broken sunglasses and
maybe their lock of hair luckily in
Zagreb Croatia a place exists where
these items can be preserved instead of
just sitting at the back of your
closet dzen gruby Chi and oinka vitsa
founders of the museum had this exact
problem drain and myself first met 20
years ago he was um Sculptor artist
doing the clubs often and I was at the
time working with the French
choreographer our relationship was great
we had a lot in common we were quite
busy at the time as well so we traveled
a lot which was really nice yeah it was
a it was a nice relationship maybe the
work was uh taking over me I was very
ambitious at the time it wasn't a a
spectacular break up it was more of like
yeah let's just split there was this
banal bunny we would take it two
different places when we would travel
without the partners and that was the
trigger for us to think okay who takes
the bunny we were sitting in a kitchen
and talking about it and it was
fascinating that something so banal
could have such a huge emotional trigger
to anybody else it was just a banal
object to you it was like you just look
at it and heart-wrenching that's where
the idea about the museum came about so
what makes an item worthy of a spot on a
plin there are no criteria you have to
meet to be accepted as a part of the
collection because I think it's the most
beautiful thing you you become part of a
huge Community across the world and
people you don't even know but we all
share this human connection through love
and um its
disappearance all the descriptions are
written by donors so whoever gives the
object he's the one behind the story I
was kind of afraid at the beginning we
have no control over it so I thought it
might be boring or repetitive and it
turned out from the start they write so
well and and you have sometimes these
really short three four sentences story
that give you like the insight and you
want to know more and they like trailer
to a movies that you want to
see as every other serious Museum we
also have a gift shop t-shirts bags
chocolates and so on but they all have a
quirky message dealing with the museum
dealing with breakup love the most
popular item is the big erasor it's
called bad memories rasor people usually
when they see see they start laughing
and they get it it's like oh I know who
this goes to does it ever get weird
working with your ex a long process of
15 years learning how to work together
respect each other that's the best thing
you can do to create something with
someone and learn how to respect
yourself and the other person in the
process and prove that it's
possible
enabling people to get rid of these
reminders and actually transforming them
into something else the process of
writing the story and packing the object
and sending it away I'm sure it provides
relief and we've heard it from so many
people and this Museum isn't just a
quirky way to spend an afternoon in
Zagreb visitors empathize so much with
other people they learn how to overcome
their own prejudices we all have on some
level through the this experience which
is for all of us the
[Music]
same